it'll be the 13th start for hermod
and the era just keeps going down it's
around four
right now four point one three to be
precise over his last three sully in 0
90 earned run average yeah and in that
time opponents are only hitting
134 he's been dominant as of late here's
murphy bounding at 222.
messi got him with the knuckle curve
ball the walk does no damage no score as
the rockies come to bat james caprilian
and i guess you could say if he could
have a bad start every four then he'd be
okay because he had a
not necessarily great one against the
seattle mariners to an old record though
as his club got him off the hook and a
four-run fourth inning about two yeah
it's about tip and that's a strikeout so
tapia strikes out to open up the bottom
of the first
marquez goes to work against chad pinder
he's going to tap one slowly toward
rogers bare hand throw to first in time
nicely done by b rod coming in hard and
making a sure throw to cj krohn well he
is smooth you can just see the natural
instincts it's short was all over that
charging and then the easy bare hand and
the good throw all in one motion it's
three ground ball outs among the four
for airmon the other was a strikeout
elvis andrews will start it off batting
208
and that is going to be a base hit
[Applause]
albus andrews with the lead off signal
bob melbourne takes it
deep breath
the ball up a little bit and
breaking ball elvis anders who has been
swinging the bat
very well lately
gets a hit
after being robbed last night a couple
of times and with two out for the second
time of the game oakland has a rudder
and scoring position two men out for
tony kemp swing and a miss as nunez held
onto it a little foul tip action into
the glove of dom and it's a
free strikeout inning for airmon marcus
nunez the first base hit today for
colorado rymel tapia now to make his way
to the plate that one slapped the other
way into left field for a base hit
around third nunez he will score and
rymel tapia delivers rbi single gives
the rockies a one nothing lead
92 mile an hour fastball you see on the
subaru strike zone away
rymel
just reaches out and touches it and goes
the other way with it
right right where a typical short stop
would be playing
let's see if seth brown can end an offer
in a big way and drive in the tying run
the pitch to brown is hit high in the
air right field blackman coming in
mcmahon going out blackman fighting the
sun but stays with it and makes the
catch and marquez again works around the
base runner stranding olson at third two
singles and a walk and caprilian already
down one nothing has a mess here brendan
rodgers now pitch from caprelian swung
on and hit towards center field canna
backing up a step makes the catch
blackman tags he comes in to score and
the rockies get the sacrifice fly from
brendan rodgers and now lead two to
nothing
brendan rodgers with a productive out
you always want the base hit of course
but you want the run a leadoff double
for tony kemp rocky's leading two to
nothing in the sixth one out and this is
shawn murphy he drills one to left way
back topia will turn and watch it off
the top of the wall plays the carrum
camp will score easily and murphy goes
to second with a double and these are on
the board it's 2-1 colorado and that
close to ty get up
but now it's 2-1
and murphy delivers his 31st rbi
that was the hanging slider the ace did
miss there's just too much real estate
out there
as well as he hit it it's still a long
way to go if you can't get a little more
air underneath it he really he really uh
got a hold of it though yeah you're
right it's it's
390 out there to left center of course
so airman marquez goes six innings four
hits allowed one run it was earned
a walk and six strikeouts matt adams
will pit chit for the rockies frankie
ball is spanked and right into the shift
tony camp in short right throws to first
for the out and kemp was playing way
into right field and adams hit the ball
right to him and romo does the job so it
is givens
who pitched in last night's game pitched
the eighth inning at three fly ball out
called strike three
chapman turns slowly and heads back to
the dugout givens gets the punch out
i'll tell you what ramon dejesus has had
an outstanding
strike zone at the bottom of the zone
today there was another one barely a
strike but it caught the bottom edge
with the a's down two to one still just
one out runners at first and third for
canna swing and a miss
canna goes down on strikes in a huge
strikeout so michael now and out away
from getting out of this spot
with kemp at the plate swung on and
missed
michael gibbons strikes out the side and
leaves runners at the corners
daniel will make his 22nd appearance and
after a sluggish start certainly by his
standards
he has really been pitching very very
well he has he's
had eight straight scoreless appearances
10 out of his last 11.
for daniel bart it's come down to
fastball command i think early on in the
season he was
struggling leaving some out over the
heart of the plate
slider didn't have his tied a break to
it but
last six weeks he's virtually been the
same guy we've seen since last year
pinder hits it sharply to rogers the
second big man for one on the first
there's the double play
rockies turn their 47th double play on
the infield
and their 51st twin kill on the year it
loads the bases for dom nunez
an opportunity to give the rockies a
two-run lead get towards left center
field on the run canada he'll make the
catch
tagging at third mcmahon he will score
canna made a good play but nunez gets
another run home 3-1 rockies brown moves
into scoring position jed lowry the
switch hitter who will bat for petite
miss
daniel bard with a six out save
the rockies go 4-2 on the home stand